COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I helped some toy makers
with their boot times.
Will performance be the hot
toy this holiday season?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Capital Fun is an
IoT toy developer,
who has been converting over
portions of their architecture
to serverless systems.
However, as their Google
Cloud Functions usage
didn't scale to meet demand
as fast as they wanted,
they quickly pinned cold
boot time as the culprit
and reached out to us to
see how they could improve
it, which totally makes sense.
Even though GCF is considered
a serverless architecture,
you still have to be aware
that there are some cold boot
time overhead as new
instances are spun up.
Now, most of the
time, your function
will already be
running an instance
and will be ready to
handle future triggers
as fast as possible.
However, your functions
might be in a cold state
because, number one, your
function has been deployed
but not triggered yet, or
number two, your function
has been idle long enough that
it was recycled for resources,
or number three,
your function is
auto-scaling to handle capacity
and creating a new instance.
In any of these cases, your
code isn't currently running,
and the next trigger event
will spin up a new instance.
Now, when it comes to GCF,
the number one contributor
to slow cold boot
performance is dependencies.
When a module boots, node.js
resolves all the require calls
from the entry point using
synchronous I/O, which
can take a significant
amount of time
if the number of
dependencies are large
or if the content itself
requires a lot of linking.
So when I saw that their GCF
module had 50 dependencies,
well, we knew where
to focus our efforts.
As a first step, we worked
with their tech team
to trim out any dependencies
that might not be needed.
This includes areas
where they might
be using one function
from a library,
but including the
entire library.
So after a lot of negotiation,
digging, and spaghetti code
clinging, we were
able to get down
to eight packages, resulting in
a 2x performance in cold boot
time.
Which was good, but there
was still work to do.
Next up, we looked at
what dependency versions
their functions
were actually using.
More popular
versions of a package
are most likely already stored
in GCF's dependency cache,
meaning that importing
and resolving
can be done much quicker.
So once we unified all of
Capital Fun's dependencies
to use the same
versions that were more
likely to be used in the cache,
we saw another nice performance
boost.
Finally, digging through
the node.js code,
we decided to set up lazy
loading of core requirements
rather than having them all
occur in cold boot phase.
This allowed us to require only
what's needed at the start,
and then switch to an async
version of the required keyword
later for specific
request handling,
bringing down the cold
boot times even further.
With these small changes,
we saw a 10x improvement
in Capital Fun's
cold boot time, which
isn't bad for a day's work.
If you want to know
more about the changes,
check out the article in
the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]